was the thing that first interested you
about this whole project the impetus to
make focus yeah I use a big word you saw
that my first I want to say impetus
tomorrow you know I love the the work of
John and Glen the the directors they did
a Crazy Stupid Love and I love that film
and when I read focus it was so
interesting because it's so many
different kinds of movies they like
completely ignores onra you know so it's
a it's a heist film but then it will be
a bizarre comedy for a while and then
it's really serious and it's great
action and then there's a love story as
you as you were where you're where it is
a love story in the film yeah there's a
there's a wonderful love story at the
center to film so I just loved how many
different styles and flavors that that
they would demand of the actors you know
and there we would be in scenes
sometimes they're like so this is so
where's this is serious right there's
that yeah yeah but have fun with it and
we just get to go through so many ranges
of the spectrum
magalie right really well for women as
well they like great female characters I
think as well they do they do and like
well we're saying they said at the heart
of it was was a love story so um yeah
there was a lot to do for Jess in that
sense because halfway through she's a
woman scorned and kind of transformers
transforms her after that so ya know
they develop it really well she's a
great giant eagle and I'm like that was
fun to kind of to bring to light yeah
it's really nice to have a character
that as one starting point and is a
totally different person by the end of
the film it's kind of nice to a play
with that so I was lucky who do you
think's in control by the end of the
film more in control between to who's in
charge
he's in charge yeah yeah thank you
pretty obviously it's pretty obvious
yeah it was pretty happy it's a we're I
am in charge oh yeah no no so I could
kind of like when the set like her just
like on the well I heard that when you
when you kind of arrived on set you have
this amazing confidence in kind of I'd
call you bossiness northern set up yeah
another thing about Margo she is
absolutely certain of who she wants to
be and what she wants to do but she's
absolutely certain of who she wants you
to be and what she wants you to do too
so that was that was that was fun in the
series she would say no not like deucey
I'm sorry hold it one second to know
like you I made a couple movies Margo
okay I have some ideas - I bet you felt
like that
no you know what's great at she's she's
right most of the time which is
fantastic right you know 90% of the time
if something doesn't feel right to her
in a scene it's it's correct you know
but but I'm a man I got to go against it
anyway so um but she her instincts are
really brilliant you know she can't
always she can't always say why it
doesn't feel right she just says just oh
just do it the way I said you know so I
just learned to do that but it was it
was a was really really fun working with
someone with that level of instincts
that was so different than my own did
you guys get much for chance to improve
on this film or was it kind of sticking
to script I feel like we am probably my
dad yeah which is surprising because
there are so many plot points that we
obviously had to hit in each scene or
get to a certain degree or hide to a
certain degree so is it didn't it
shouldn't have left much room for improv
but the guys still really encouraged it
is it one scene that sticks out for you
that was that was a kind of really good
example of I think the everything the
end seeing oh my goodness yeah and say I
don't want to ruin it for people who
haven't seen it but when we did the end
scene um it's it's quite dramatic but
there were takes where we were just like
in hysterics yeah and when you watch it
it's it's it looks like it makes sense
ya know what's really great what they do
that's fantastic is they create a set
where everyone's involved so they get
what they want and you're rolling
and they'll let anyone yell out a line
that you know funny like somebody just
yells something out this funny you say
oh yeah yeah Marco say that say that
somebody the grip says hey he should say
go you know you're like okay well your
lips buddy say that say that so it's
like this real great in it together
everyone's working towards the same goal
it was a little awkward for me in the
love scene but I will put your leg up
would you like and I've done this before
okay questions from you guys let's start
off this slightly you know you feel
comfortable with stuff yes yes
absolutely that's my girl that's my girl
wait for the microphone wait tell
everyone who you are yeah I was just
gonna uh my name is Rita I'm still from
Finland okay again I just want to know
was it difficult to learn these tricks
and have you been wrote hurt and how if
you have been robbed how did it feel um
it didn't feel like anything cuz I
didn't notice I was being robbed at the
time I've been pickpocketed very
effectively and I've been blatantly
robbed so you know that I was aware of
Margo gets robbed all the time I'm like
how do you manage to get robbed because
I'm nothing but three okay yeah yeah you
she grew up grew up in in Australia
where like people are nice all the time
so she's got you I was like when I leave
the house 5% of my money's in my sock
another piece of it that you put some
under your arm like you split all your
stuff up cause you know you're gonna get
robbed and how difficult were they kind
of the tricks against the trade to learn
a lot harder than it looks
yeah um the more you understand about it
the easier it gets so the more you look
into the psychological side of it the
more the physical side makes sense
mm-hm and because you to begin with
can't believe that you could steal
something in plain sight you're just
like they will catch me there's no way
I'm going to try that but if you and
Apollo Robbins I think you've all met
yeah I mean when he explains you know
distraction and things I
not yeah it makes the physical side of
stealing a lot easier try doing mates
and stuff since I have yeah yeah no but
you know what's really great though is
that you the the psychological side for
me the human behavior side you just
can't imagine that a human brain is that
feeble like we think that we're aware
and we're paying attention and we think
we're on top of things but right now
everyone's looking this way anything
could be going on over there and the
more attention we put forward the it's
just completely blind you have such huge
blind spots
Apollo showed us a video a surveillance
video at a fight right he thought about
the fight where so the second the the
the fighter gets knocked down the whole
crowd cheers and he goes in and he shows
us 30 people pickpocketing at the point
that's a gun I'm like oh my god like how
many times have you been in a fight and
going yeah and the people I sit and they
wait for that moment of complete
distraction and right into your bag
right in and he's going around I'm like
this is insane no but people don't even
know that this is happening around us
right next question we just made 400
just now of course like walking is very
London you thought it got easier he
stand up sir please yeah sure hi I'm
mark ocurro from film - reviews on that
I said since you've learned how to sort
of read people more and do all these
tricks
have you been to Vegas have you tried
your skills out yeah well I actually I
went to Vegas with Apollo which is a
different way to go to Vegas well first
of all cuz nobody allows you to go in
anywhere with Apollo or they know he
can't come in here
but you had me to try to eat said listen
he wanted me to walk into a store and he
said I want you to just pick something
up put it in your pocket and walk out
and what you realize is it takes such
courage to to even try it because I'm
like I'm Will Smith I get it you know
it's like that's a pretty good
distraction
but it's terrifying it takes such
absolute ice water in your veins to put
your hand in somebody's pocket or grab
something and and take it but it is um I
realized and what I learned with it with
it with the character it's also a thrill
it's like jumping out of an airplane and
it's like speeding in a car it's like
being that close to someone turning
around and saying hey will you do it you
know it's like that is a serious
addictive kind of thrill let's hope
you're not going to continue that day
like that oh you know I'm done with this
movie stuff and we've got a lady here
you sign up please cut my gorgeous there
I will that's a lovely outfit I like
that is it open ask a lot of people
confuse it for dress sorry yeah
yeah right yeah honestly don't you ever
make that mistake yeah yeah he did you
see I think I'm sorry
security my name's Kayla from IGN I like
to ask you um this from from one
character here with a special gift to
the forthcoming Suicide Squad you've
played a superior before in Hancock and
all three characters have dubious morals
mmm how would you say each differs oh
wow that's interesting
um I think I think how do they differ
that's interesting I hadn't even thought
about those as one um I guess I like the
concept of dubious morals always likely
to play in that area but the character
and focus his issue is he is committed
to lying right he is committed to
wearing a mask and no one ever knowing
who he is and the idea that you can't
have love if you're lying you know you
can't have that that thing that we all
search for if you're not being authentic
and living without the mask so morally
he's
made a decision that being a liar is the
only way he can survive he protects
himself absolutely
with Hancock Hancock doesn't remember so
that's an interesting thing also not
having any memory of who he was he has
no idea what his moral standing was and
then suicide squad that's interesting I
was a we just got started on that and I
think I haven't explored the the
psychology enough of Deadshot somebody
who can take money to kill people
how he justifies that for for himself so
let's do I still have a little bit to
work work to do on that but in my life
in general and in my career um those are
the types of roles that I'm pushing more
towards those kinds of questions you
know what was interesting for me with
focus now is in my life
my journey is around vulnerability and
authenticity so to have a guy who has
just decided to lie was really
interesting to test the the boundaries
of how wide open and how authentic can I
be in real life by exploring the other
side and the character okay thank you
gentlemen down in front here can you get
my and I don't care what you say it
looks like a dress so have it no Morea I
just want to talk to you about the
on-screen chemistry um it was fairly
electrifying at times oh how much of
what was the key to that success or how
much of a dream Martinez had anything to
do with that I know yeah that was a good
laugh right down ha ha wow that was
hearty yeah it was a really good laugh
yeah that was in a black family that
would be considered a really good laugh
guys
good party african-american laughs you
got there I'm so chemistry chemistry
Gerber's dude well we've said a couple
of times it was something neither of us
were really expecting but for some
reason when we walked into the room we
just really got along and that kind of
continued throughout the shoot and it
made every scene exciting and fun and
it's not really something you can
manufacture so it wasn't forced or
planned I suppose it just existed
already which was handy because we've
talked about like when Margo came to
read for for the role that she didn't
think there was any chance that she was
going to get it because of how different
we are you know I mean I'm uh and the
long list of actresses I was yeah yeah
yeah yeah when we down I'm 46 and Margo
was 23 when we when we did it so it
seemed like it wouldn't work in that way
and I'm from Philly and she's from
Australia
so there could e different there's
obvious genetic differences yeah so but
for some reason it just worked perfectly
you know when you see it on-screen none
of those questions come come up you know
oh god why would they do that it's just
like it's a it's like a wonderful puzzle
it works together it works very well
very well I enjoyed myself I don't know
if you if you there it was all right
okay I figured I figured it was okay can
you gentleman in the glasses on the
second row over here please thank you
hello this is not a dress by the way
there's a question for Margo it's
probably safe to say that the biggest
gamble you've taken so far is leaving
Australia to go to Hollywood what gave
you that impacts you can you tell us
anything at the moment about the film
you're gonna be making with Tina Fey
currently filming that with the writer
directors of focus are directing the
Tina Fey untitled Tina Fey project as
it's now called so yeah it's really nice
to be working with them again and a lot
of the same crew members I was the first
part of that question use the word
impetus I don't know what the question
impetus was my word for this press
conference no one is allowed to repeat
any word oh the gamble the biggest
gamble moving to moving to America it
didn't feel like a gamble at the time it
kind of felt like the only way to keep
moving forward so it just seemed like a
logical next step a big one for sure and
yeah definitely terrifying but I did a
lot of pre-planning and saved all my
money
preparing for up to three years
unemployment which didn't turn out to be
so I was like II totally totally I don't
know why it's all happening he didn't
have the microphone for that question
he added a question that's not fair oh
yeah mine and the lovely red cardigan
hmm not a dress marching socks though
Wow quite smart anybody yeah matching
mic and everything yeah hi guys again a
question for Margo tricky one Leonardo
DiCaprio Will Smith I was hot yeah wait
a minute wait a minute that's a good
question on to the that's a good
question your honor will you please
instruct the witness to answer the
question I'm sir the question I can't
win with this either way I'm gonna get
in trouble
okay but and then what did you take from
working with well you know it's
something I took from both of them and
they actually have a few things in
common they have extremely huge profiles
but on but one of our profiles is huge
it into others
trying to give you a bit despite how I
don't want to say it now but devices
like that when they work walk onto set
they're extremely professional they are
so courteous to everyone on set and it
just goes to show that if someone in
their position can can behave that way
and be so decent and then there's no one
can be a dick on set like you just
there's no need for it so I'm yeah it
was good it was I said dude sorry he's
at a press conference you've said anal
in our interview yesterday hey but it
wasn't it was like as a joke okay
gentlemen to plug the green good my
going to so Bollywood I do I love I've
been there a few times I got I hung out
with some of the best I would I was
there I think it was proper it was four
years ago when when Big B wasn't feeling
well and everything shut down and I was
like now this is how actors are supposed
to be treated you know he wasn't he
wasn't feeling well and you know people
were at the hospital and you know it was
like everything shut everything down to
make sure he was okay so we could learn
some things for from Bollywood
treatment of actors I would gladly love
it's fantastic I'm lady the back we got
microphones were please yeah that's you
yes don't up thank you hi I'm Lucille
from Russells and I have two questions
actually one for Margo and one for will
you embodied funny funny characters
dramatic characters so what was your
challenge here with Nicky's character
and Margo as a woman why do you think
just like forgave Nikki for being such a
loser with you too big
hmmm I think it took her a little while
to figure yeah kind of year
punished him yeah about three years and
she could have punished him for a while
I I think eventually she just realized
that that sort of game didn't matter and
she didn't want to play the game anymore
and if he was ya willing to give it at
all give it his all she would to like
that hmm
um I'm sorry I was just thinking
Brussels head I've heard you I was like
there has to be a Brussels joke there I
wasn't listen to the question oh no no
you said Oh funny you said about being
funny yes you said about being funny
funny happy being funny you know um I
think with with with this character was
really great and with these directors
it's never it's not straightforward
funny it's like it's dead serious and
then they manage to figure out how the
situation makes it makes it funny and
that's very different from me you know
I'm from the American sitcom school
right you know so for me you do not make
people have to guess whether or not it's
funny you know you go really hard at it
so it was it was a little bit of a
different tonal quality for me that was
fun to play it it always felt like I
wasn't doing anything boy lady here
question I never go over to the bucket
hi Marian gray from South Africa
Queensland for mr. Smith yes so you're
involved in charities then would you
like to say a few words on that and have
you bought your house yet no that would
know that was I was uh involved with the
4 double 664 Nelson Mandela's foundation
and we thought it was an interesting we
launched MTV on the continent of Africa
as of probably about a decade ago 12
years ago we launched MTV with Nelson
Mandela's foundation and that that was
one of the most you know fantastic
experiences of my career and that I had
found a house that I loved it so much we
shot
Ali and I've I was there with Nelson
Mandela and Muhammad Ali in South Africa
right so Mandela on one side and Ali on
the other so it was like absolute
certainty that I'm nothing in this world
you know so you know I was sitting there
with them and I found a house in Durban
I think was - it was a 2000 it was right
before 9/11 and just at after 9/11 I
thought it was for as an American I
thought that was a bad time to be moving
so we never we never got the place down
there okay over here I didn't write the
back force with it you keep standing up
it was great yeah yeah hi I'm Mohammed
from moxme
hey lieutenant with an elite oh all
right last night she asked you Edith
Bowman and Jackie what was that that
lady that lady asked you she asked
Margaret has she ever seen Fresh Prince
of bel-air and you said no what how does
that make you feel well and don't bring
it up again no no no no I mean I say
thank you so no I think this is a
fantastic time to discuss it
I'd love to talk about this off the Kris
Kobach's said okay yeah yeah and we're
all gonna lose Bennett dunce Alfonso
will mmm
will is the greatest dancer sing it
sooner there you go just in front there
adamance time wise and muggy you just
we're just saying about your instincts
on set and this is a shortage of women
and directors in Hollywood is that
something you'd be interested in going
into yeah definitely it's something I
plan on doing down the track yeah she
directed a big part of this one I swear
I'm not bossy in any other aspect of my
life it's just one set and then we'll
walk away across here please
hi guys Luke here feel from well t47
that's about your chemistry I'm
wondering how much show you guys looking
forward to reuniting for Suicide Squad
movie and how are your characters and
chemistry differ in that film compared
to focus I'm really I'm looking forward
to I don't know what it's going to be
terrible
yeah I don't know what a carriage is
what the relationships really going to
be it's ever-changing yeah yeah but it's
really cool they the waited David air
works it's all images all ideas and he
holds the screenplay holds the
screenplay
and he just keeps sending you things
about your character you just want you
to be prepared for for anything so I
think we're gonna be allies for sure
yeah yeah we're definitely allies I
really I really we're not being
secretive we just actually don't yeah we
actually yeah he only sends you your
characters stuff so you don't know
what's going on with the other
characters and things I think he wants
it to come alive on set when you start
that uh middle of April Yeah right okay
gentlemen here pass the mic along here
please thank you hi Derrick Smith from
The Sunday Post newspaper I don't want
to admit this haven't just said my name
but I when I was 14 I stole a
pornographic magazine from a newsagent
really oh and I just want to guess that
I could have guessed that it was
pre-internet yeah and I just wondered if
you two have ever a similar story on
your past do you but I step on toes all
the time yeah let me have it I can't so
no I've never stolen anything why is it
that you think the conman films we still
have the sympathy with the con artists
as audiences that's interesting yeah
we've talked about that a little bit
it's kind of easy to find empathy with
the protagonist of a story because
you're hearing and seeing everything
from their perspective I think yeah I
think people have a particular
fascination with conan heist films
because there is something a little
dangerous about it and perhaps it's our
way of living vicariously through
someone else I think there's also the
idea that in these films if you're going
to steal something
you're stealing something from someone
who has a lot and most times is someone
who would be unwilling to share so I
just think deep inside of all of us
everyone kind of feels like every every
yeah the Robin Hood sort of feeling and
you
love for when someone gets their
comeuppance okay don't anyone use come
up in this webshop like that's my
impetus and come up it's our mind for
today about three minutes you covered
Will Smith if you have finished a movie
and decided is successful everyone waits
the next time for a movie which is even
as good or better yeah isn't this a hard
thing how do you find your stories to
have a brain trust the other thing is in
your movies you always have the most
beautiful partners don't you have
programs at home very buddy the first
part of questions they're always trying
to top what you did last time
um I I have I've stopped doing that that
was a thing from me I was in a really
competitive place for a good larger part
of my career where every time everything
has to be number one and it has to do a
half a billion around the world and all
of that and it stopped being fun you
know it was it was a whole lot less fun
and now I've sort of settled into a
place emotionally where I just wanted to
create and want to be with great people
I want to have fun and not concern
myself with the outcome of the movie
less goal oriented and more path
oriented and the other side is funny but
uh Jada found out that Margo was doing a
movie and we looked and she we go on the
internet we look to see you know to see
pictures of Margo and she looked at mark
on she said you better get in the gym
she said do not embarrass me on camera
with that girl get yourself together
I'm on the back row there and then we'll
come to the lady to you hi I'm yeah goes
from Greece her after focus are you
still trusting people and is there a
trust issue in Hollywood a trust you
know it's funny what what what I
realized that it was good and that in
focus is everybody's running a con you
know and that was one of the first
things that Apollo said he said you when
you think in these terms you have to
understand every single person is
running a con everyone wakes up in the
morning you choose your clothes you
choose what you say you choose where you
go you're choosing everything not based
on authentically who you are you choose
the things you choose to have the
outcome that you want you hide the parts
of yourself that you don't like you
accentuate the parts of yourself that
you do like and then you just make up
some things to pretend like you are to
pretend that you're certain things that
you're not in order to achieve the goals
so for me in that it became very easy to
work through trust because you know that
when you're starting in the beginning
and you meet someone you know that your
first three or four months of
interaction with that person are going
to be full of facade so you learn to see
through and what would uh what Apollo
taught that was really interesting is
generally the things that people
accentuate are the exact opposite of
what the truth is you know so if a
person like me for example I'm really
loved and I'm out and all of that so
that's a sign that there is a an
insecure side and the more loud and the
more right that a person is the more the
five-year-old little boy inside of there
is scared and nervous you know the more
that someone is sexy and and does all of
that the more that you know that the
other side of that is a part of what the
the truth of the the inner psychology is
so it is it starts the
be easier you can trust people more
actually once you're aware that right
I'm lady here back then will come down
to you in the front
thank you very much Assyria for miss
Payne I have a question for you if did
you like to gambling now that you have
you learn some tricks obviously is no
legal but maybe the psychological think
you can take advantage now after knowing
that people are so predictable and this
is a petition it's not a question I mean
I see your faces I see your bodies I see
even your teeth in a big screen please
make us a favor be together just improve
the human evolution Wow alright well
we're going to get started on that
straightaway well you know as as actors
and when you're telling stories a big
part of that if you get to the real core
of it and you get to the the most human
part that's what the attempt is you're
trying to create something that creates
conversation that creates a new way to
look at the world and the the basis of
storytelling was is to transfer human
ideas and and wisdom so so at the at the
core of that the the major attempt is
always human evolution great answer
maybe in the front row please we'd get
microphones all right stand up hello how
are you celebrity friends who would you
like oh wow you've got more celebrity
friends than I do
umm so pulling off a con what would the
what would the con be that's interesting
I I don't I don't know what the what the
con would be that I would want to pull o
convince someone you know Will Smith
you'd be afraid yeah that would be a
pretty big con well that would be easy
I'll just cover my ears you know
soon as I cover my ears I'm that will
yeah that no that is fine yes it's like
I'm all silhouette people recognize me
from a rounded corner the little piece
of my ears stick it out around the
corner it's uh it's it's fantastic it's
an American thing to people when you
have the ears me Barack Mickey Mouse
it's a thing where where people just
love the years they need a hot will
smart make it your talk okay can we go
with the gentleman there and the lady
next to you back hey guys
will question for yourself you mentioned
before about getting into the studio
working with Kanye West's reponsibility
potentially doing a world tour or not
even plausible at all I named Margo
actually Fonda das because well a couple
years ago and no disrespect to Ramsay
Street but look where you are right now
you have to pinch yourself go holy [ __ ]
head of this huh I was watching myself
when I was there we don't yeah there is
no to myself when I was on neighbours
and yeah I'm definitely still pinching
myself now it would equally is exciting
at the time but music oh yeah so I went
in with my new studio with Kanye a
couple times I know just exploring you
know he's a he's pushing me a little bit
but I haven't I gotta wrap you started
writing Shh when we you're not that why
are you the averages I'm not yes I say
yes Margot's her she's heard one or two
things though on the movie I would I was
working stop you come on
I'm just curious what's happening but I
don't know what's happening with it I
haven't made a decision yet to make so
but I have I always record I've never
stopped recording so I always make songs
and records and and I let Margo hear
something which obviously was a mistake
reception when you know I know it's so
crazy
oh yeah no if I if I if if I if I can
find something I want to find that that
well you know it's really hard it's like
you get rusty you know so it's like I
have thoughts and I have ideas I have
that I want to say but artistically and
poetically I can't get them to come out
of my pen so if if if Kanye has his way
I will I will definitely do some
recording this year Oh Calvin you did
your teen apart last year in Scotland
oh yeah yeah so Calvin Lee I went yeah I
was trying to get inspired so I have you
know people that go hang with out I did
a couple weeks out with Calvin Harris
last year and just I'm just trying to
just trying to you know find that thing
gentleman in the front here also you got
my Google Forest and pass it in front
first props to Jada cuz you looked
amazing
you mentioned the age gap and I think
you know person of your age you look
amazing but do you still feel that yeah
there's women who get a lot of pressure
to look good but you as a matter you
feel that now your age there is a lot of
pressure for you to maintain your
fitness if you're going to be starred
opposite women half your age yeah you
know it's it's um it gets more and more
difficult I used to be able to eat
whatever I want and then in six weeks I
could get in any shape I wanted to get
into but that's not the case anymore
where we're around the twelve or
fourteen week mandatory training to do
anything but but I love it I enjoy I
enjoy the discipline of it for me
working on on your body is the beginning
of everything you know your mind starts
to work better you're the better husband
a better father a better friend and life
is just better when you you know care
for your body at the highest level thank
you and gentleman in front of you could
pass the mic hi I'm um from a monomyth
Cindy Li film my question is for well
there's a great love story and back and
forth between yours and Margo's
characters in the film as someone who's
played a big doctor in hinging what do
you think it would have made of Nikki's
efforts in this film
oh my god yeah hitch hitch wouldn't work
with Mickey good I think that was
perfect for me part of the the fun of
this character you know work
so hard and so much reading and studying
and marriage counseling and parental
books and I like doing all of that to
figure out the right way so to play a
character who just does it all wrong
you know that just every step of the way
the most insane choices you know and not
know spoiler alert but you know the
choice in the middle of the film you
know with with Nicky and Jess is is
generally irretrievable like that's just
a mistake that you'll just you'll never
get beyond that one and then after that
to to realize that he's still in love is
like do what are you doing you know but
it was you know it's fun for me to to to
play those things but Nick Nicki's
Nikki's a mess and guys thank you so
much that's all we've got time for today
huge round of applause please for our or
are you guys thank you very much
you